I'm very excited for the talk today
um so let's bring my screen I think I'm
already
sharing my my slides so hello everybody
uh I'm I'm excited to be here at Pi data
uh sharing a little bit about some of
the things uh that it's
close to my heart uh so interesting
thing
so when I Was preparing for this talk I
wasn't too sure what I was going to talk
about
I always have a lot of things to talk
about like there are a lot of things
that I can say uh I always have some
opinion and then I like to share the
things that I learned
but I didn't share I was I wasn't sure
exactly if it was a good fit the things
that I wanted to say that it was a good
fit for the audience attending a
conference then I started from the
beginning so I went back and then I was
like okay great so this is a pi data
conference so it's a conference probably
my talk should be around python
um
but then I thought agree again you know
I don't think I know enough
python to give a cold talk on it
then I went to the pi data website and
then I started reading about it I
started reading about the pi data
conference
one of the things that it says it says
Pi data is a educational program and I
mean okay great education so awesome
then I was reading again and then I
found another word
communities
and then I found data science
and then our and then share ideas learn
grow together
interesting because these are some of
the words that have me around uh with me
throughout my career and that have like
not only what I've been doing but a lot
of things that you all have been doing
and I feel like the common team here is
that I see the intersection of all these
words is about communities
when you think about languages and the
ecosystem for example
we need a community around it I'm a huge
believer that foreign language a project
or a product should be successful
we need to have a community around it
so for example for you to learn
something new it's much better to have a
Community Learning with you where you
can learn and share your knowledge where
you can grow together where you can
brainstorm ideas it is the sense of
belonging and togetherness
then it was time to think about the
title of the talk
I was listening to the police
uh this very old song I think it was
like what the 80s probably uh the song
is called every little thing she does is
Magic
and I was like yeah it's interesting huh
all these words and and the song
maybe this should be the title of my
talk
I love the song I love the words in the
song
but I don't think does his magic is
like the good title for the talk maybe I
should do something like this every
little thing we do is Magic
and then I'm like okay but we who is we
we what is the we here so maybe
that was the title the title of my talk
for today is every little thing we do
with for by the community is magic so my
name is Gabriella de queroz I'm a prison
Paul Cloud Advocate at Microsoft working
on the Education team on AIML and data
science
foreign
ER of Our Ladies AI inclusive member of
the Art Foundation and advisory
counseling member at the non-focus
but let me start by talking about my
current role at Microsoft so I want to
share a little bit about my work the
things that I'm doing over there
so as I mentioned I'm a education Cloud
Advocate working with students and
Educators across the globe
and this has a lot to do with learn with
education with share with grow and of
course communities
so the mission of our team is to enable
students to obtain the technical skills
they want to start and progress in their
career so this is the mission that we
have this is what we are trying to
achieve that's that's what we are doing
so we we welcome students and we provide
this inclusive accessible and authentic
environment to learn
we also guide them we guide them in all
the aspects of Learners technical
Skilling journey and employability and
we connect
we connect people to Global Technical
communities to products into that a
diverse set of experiences so we welcome
we guide we connect and then we hope
that this cycle keeps going on where
the the students that got for this this
process they come again and they welcome
new students and then they guide the new
students and then they connect with the
new students and their whole community
let me talk a little bit about the
things that we offer so as I mentioned
we are focused on students and Educators
so there is a set of offerings that we
have for each students and educators
one of the things is what we call the
student Hub where it's a place for you
to learn
and and to progress your career when
there are a lot of free resources and
you know I know that we all love free
resources and we all love uh
paths and ways for us to jumpstart the
career or like even to progress on their
career and you don't need to be a
student to go through this but even
though the focus of our work is on the
students and educator so and they
shouldn't have you can see some of the
different careers or paths that you can
take for example data science uh data
analysts and then the other piece around
how to get notice in your career or by
recruiters or like what are some tips
that we can offer how about interview
and then there is a whole set of package
uh there's a lot of like certifications
uh you can get Azure which is a
Microsoft product you can get Azure for
students you can get the GitHub student
develop pack that comes with a lot of
things and you know one of the things
that I'm very passionate about right now
that I'm going to touch on a little bit
is about code spaces uh
gold spaces is a new product by GitHub
and it's the idea is that you can go to
any GitHub repository and you can start
your own environment in seconds so you
can use for example any editor so here I
have the visual studio or vs code or
Jupiter or jetbrings uh you can use that
for your environment so in my case as a
data scientist I will probably be using
vs code or Jupiter notebook so we cannot
work anywhere from anywhere and device
in a browser for example I don't need to
have my desktop I can do everything on
my phone as well so it's very
interesting to think about
democratization and the power of this
type of like environments because in
some countries in some places they don't
have access to to computers all they
have is like a cell phone so they can
access and do the whole environment even
using your cell phone some of the things
that you can do with course space so as
I mentioned you can use any any device
you can start your own environment very
fast you can model train and analyze
your data you can run Jupiter notebooks
right from from the browser you can fix
bugs and secure code right from an issue
so there's a lot of like integration
between GitHub uh everything that we do
in the repo and code space so you don't
have to leave that environment to
continue to do your work
foreign
students uh one of the the main things
that they announced a few weeks ago at
GitHub Universe was that for students
they get 90 hours of code spaces for
free every month so uh you go and you
sign up you go through the whole GitHub
process of like signing up as a student
and you get 90 hours of free usage every
month and every month it resets and you
go again and you can use it every every
month
one of the things that my team has been
developing is something that we call
cold space templates
and we have again two paths we have one
for students and one for teachers so for
students is that we teach you how to use
code space to set up or or to start your
python environment and for teachers uh
we show you how you can teach python
using Code spaces so these are two
templates uh that is now living under uh
or or living on the GitHub education uh
uh organization or umbrella so you can
find these materials over there which is
very interesting there are some videos
that guides you through the whole uh
what is happening on the behind the
scenes on the code space how does it
work what are the things that you can do
so there is a lot of like tutorials uh
either from the students perspective or
from the teacher's perspective uh
another interesting thing about code
spaces
um especially like when when we are
developing something as a data scientist
let's say I'm using Python and then
there is a whole setup of environment
that I need to do uh and and and it's
very common for us you get into this
argument where if I share something with
a co-worker the co-worker comes to me
and say hey Gabriella
you know it's not working and I'm like
well it is working on my computer
so it should work so there is this whole
conflict on the environment on the setup
of the environment making sure that we
can reproduce the other things that the
your teammate or your your colleague are
doing or the teacher with the students
like making sure that we have all the
same uh environment
so let's see how this works so I want to
go and show you a little bit how the
code space Works uh and hopefully this
will go smoothly so
um I'll go to my GitHub uh
profile and I think I have it opened
somewhere here so let's see all right so
if I go over here to my repo
you know you can see like I have some
ripples repositories over here but I'm
interested in this one that I I created
last night uh When I Was preparing for
this demo so you can see that there is
not much going on over here I not even
I'm not completed uh I didn't completely
read me so there is not much information
but what I want to show you is like how
can you use code space uh
within GitHub so let me make this a
little bit bigger to make sure that you
all can see hopefully yes
so before the way that we are used to do
is like we clone the repo in our local
environment or we fork or we download
and then we can start working on it well
don't forget we need to set up the
environment right so there is a whole
thing that we need to do all the
packages and libraries that we need to
install uh with code spaces you don't
have to worry about that so you know
it's all your workspace in the cloud uh
there are a few ways that you can do
this so I can like you can see that I
have a pair that's very simple pandas
notebook uh with some uh
some functions and some things that I
was interested in I'm going back but
like I don't want to download I don't
want to Fork I don't want to clone
anything I can come over here and then
you see this tab called space I actually
have one running but there are a few
things that you can do
if you click over here you can see that
there are some uh examples but I don't
want to go over here what I want to do
is here
the environment but actually I want to
show you something else
now I have a bunch of them uh open over
here of course what I'm looking for is
something else oh it's not this one
it's already open
now I have a bunch of like code spaces
open that's fine uh so you can create a
cool space on Main which is this plus
sign over here uh two things that I want
to show over here and probably because I
have it open and I'm going to close
because otherwise this is going to mess
up my environment uh what I did is I'm
creating this new code space environment
and right now you can see it's setting
up the remote connection so making sure
that everything that I have on my repo
it's being transferred in a way to this
environment so it's it's kind of like
reading it but I'm not going to go
anywhere I'm not going to my computer
everything is going to show up over here
so all the files that I had on my repo
it gets under this interface over here
and if you don't know this interface
this is the visual vs code
so this is exactly how the vs code looks
like uh there are few things interesting
over here and I'm not showing uh the
IPython notebook or the Jupiter notebook
yet one of the interesting thing is like
if I have vs code on my computer and I
have you know I love extensions I love
to configure my whole uh my whole uh IDE
to look like the way that I like so
there are a lot of things that I saw I I
changed the team I changed the colors I
add extensions uh I'm a sublimer I used
to use Sublime a lot so all the
shortcuts I know from Sublime so I could
move over to vs code so I don't have to
learn in new shortcuts so there are a
lot of things that we can do but one
interesting thing is uh I can turn on
the the sync so
whatever setup I have on my local
machine for example I can also transfer
over to my browser so I just need to
turn on the settings the settings sync
um so what I want to show you here it's
like I have my IPython or Jupiter
notebook I python it's like I'm old
school so that's why I tell I say all
the the time I Python and I Jupiter so I
opened the Jupiter notebook and it looks
like a Jupiter uh that you are familiar
with the thing is it's it's the color is
different because of like my uh
uh my customization but you can see that
I have everything that you have in a in
a Jupiter notebook I'm going to clear
outputs of all cells so we can run this
together you can see that it's running
python uh it's same the same look and
feel that you are used to and then I can
run my comments as we I used to do so
it's running I'm going just to minimize
this a little bit so you can see so what
I'm doing here is importing uh the
libraries that I'm interested in using
and then I'm reading a CSV from this
GitHub repo then I just want to see
how does this data frame look like okay
so I can see the header and and all the
the roles okay let's do some describe
let's see let's get the description of
the data great so there is some
description I can get some info great
what else I have over here I can sort
the values and then I'm going to do uh
some more thing like I'm going to apply
a function and then I'm going to plot
I'm also going to group by and create a
bar plot and then I'm going to do a
scatter plot even though some of the
things here doesn't make sense but I
just want to show you how we can do this
uh without any setup everything on the
browser
another interesting thing that I like in
this interface is if there is any change
that I do over here
uh it's going to show uh if you out if I
want to push to my GitHub repo so if
there is any change let's suppose I want
to add something here create exploratory
data analysis I want to add something
like uh
this is for
uh Pi beta global
Global demo great it's over here and
then it's going to save and then
probably it's going to say hey Gabriella
you did change something over here and
then I can see in the div in the browser
what is the change that is happening uh
and then I can go and update and create
a message
um add header to The Notebook this is my
message
I'm going to commit
the other thing that I love about this
is it gives you some messages which I
still have over here just to make sure
that what I'm doing is correct
so I'm going to say yes and it's going
to say okay great so now let's sync the
changes let's push and this is the other
thing that I love it's not like it's not
saying push your commit it's saying hey
let's sync so if you think about the
words here think it's easier for us to
understand what this is thing that we
are trying to do over here so we are
going to think okay the action will pull
and push commits okay great awesome
um just for curiosity I want to see I
want to go back to my repo and see if
this got
update it oh yes it did 35 seconds ago
so great so awesome so you can do all of
this in your browser there are so many
other things that you can do over here
that you can explore and play around and
understand what is going on I would say
that if you want to just do the minimum
this is all you need to run your
notebook on code spaces uh the other
thing that I was trying to show you but
for some reason wasn't uh coming up for
me
here was
I think it was this no it's not this oh
yeah ah
so I can't the other way it's like you
can specify the number of cores for
example uh what is the region uh which
branch you want to try so like let's say
we have two branches one that is in
production one is that is in staging you
can replicate the whole staging
environment for example uh in your code
spaces uh in this case I only have one
bridge I'm not doing anything very
sophisticated so two core is good enough
and then you can create but this is
another way a few uh customizing your
environment I'm going to stop this oh
let's do this again so the other thing
that I was looking uh to show you it's
here let's say I don't like vs gold I
like the Jupiter notebook the white
background and then the whole UI so you
can come over here uh and then you can
open in there are a few options the
options that I was showing you before uh
which is was the default was this one
but you can open your local machine uh
using vs code or you can do also like
Jupiter Labs so that's what I'm going to
do now so what is doing now is setting
up this code space if I have uh
if I have a I was reading the questions
I'll I'll get to the questions a little
bit later uh so it's setting up my
environment it's some it takes a little
bit but it's like setting up making sure
that everything that I need is over
there I'm going to open my notebook
which is this one over here
and again the same look and feel as the
regular notebook this is the Jupiter
notebook running so if you are more
familiar if you like this interface
better you can use your IDE that you
like the most uh so you can do the same
things that I was doing over there you
can run all your comments uh comments
um I'm going to describe I'm going to
get some info and and so on all the
other things you know so this is
something that I really want to show you
all how to do this using Code spaces and
I'm excited about this because
one you as a user you get three hours
but you as a student you get more hours
even more hours so you get 90 hours so
let me go back to my presentation here
awesome
so what are the other things that we do
so we also have some programs as a
student you can become what we call a
student ambassador and so they shouldn't
Ambassador is a program that provides
plenty of opportunities for you to learn
and Lead so you can make a difference
and Empower those around you
I love this program because again it
goes back to the communities it's like
you building this community you being
part of this community you're learning
you you are learning together you are
growing together you are sharing with
others uh there is a code for um from
for my student in Bangladesh that I I
like where
they mentioned this so being a student
ambassador gives you the feeling of
belonging
it not only helped me learn new skills
but also gain confidence it allowed me
to connect with a diverse group I love
this code because this is all about
Community it's all about belonging it's
all about learning it's all about new
skills it's all about confidence it's
all about connecting so it's all about
what like that we learn we share we
create we grow so as a cloud Advocate we
learn we share we create we nurture
communities and we grow together and
with the hope that students will pay
these forwards to their peers and next
Generations
in talking about paying it forward I
want to shift gears a little bit but
before I just want to uh make sure that
I'm that I I have one question on the
chat about uh if bootcamp students get
free Azure hours yes it uh you get if
you are a student so make sure that you
go through the link that I share with
you I'll add more links to the to the
chat in a bit uh uh so you can go and
see what what we have but we have a
something called Azure for students
where you get free credits you get
access to a lot of services that you can
use so again shifting gears a little bit
let's talk about the paint forwards like
the cycle that I always talk about like
everything is a cycle uh even with as a
cloud Advocate it's also a cycle that we
are doing so let me talk about the the
two communities that I founded one is
the Our Ladies so our ladies and let me
step back and talk about R so I don't
know how many people here in the
audience know about R hopefully a lot of
us or you know about R so R is a
programming language that it was created
a long time ago and it was used at first
for the only data analysis and and by
statisticians and nowadays R is being
used by a variety of of professionals
your students in different areas and
domains and our ladies is a organization
that promotes diversity in the art
community via meetups mentorship
in a friendly and safe environment and
then the other community that I found in
2019 is the AI inclusive where we change
a little bit of I change a little bit
the focus on being more
language agnostic in a way but it's more
focusing AI but there is the same the
same idea of like increasing the
representation and participation of
minority groups in this case in Ai and
both of the the organization is very
based in communities uh basing it's
Community Based for AI inclusive we are
building also this community to make AI
more inclusive to everyone
uh and because it uh this year was the
the the 10th anniversary uh of our
ladies and October was when we hosted
our first Meetup uh I wanna go and talk
a little bit about our ladies so it's a
I'm going to focus from now on uh on the
organization and show how this
organization is an example of the
importance of having a community
but let me do another step back and let
me talk about why and how a ladies was
born
um
you can probably tell that I have an
accent I'm from Brazil so I moved from
Brazil to San Francisco 10 years ago
so in 2012
and when I got here in San Francisco it
was very interesting because I was
trying to figure out what to do I was I
came as a student so I was coming to do
a masters
and then
I found out something called Meetup
and then when I found out about this
thing called Meetup meetup.com it was
like my eyes opened I was like Wow there
is so many things happening in this
meetup.com uh world that I have no that
I had no idea
and
I joked that it was kind of like going
to the Disneyland where you have so many
options you don't know which attraction
you are going to see in my case I was
like which Meetup should I join which
Meetup should I go what should I do like
I was totally like uh when is like
overwhelmed by the options and and
completely uh
happy with all the options that there
were over here and and I started to sign
up for different meetups so I signed up
to the data visualization group for the
Hadoop for the machine learning for the
data mining for the bicycle so many
different groups uh
I joined and I started going and I
back then as a student as you know the
student life is very hard especially
when you are coming from a different
country it's very expensive so our money
we don't have a lot of money to spend
it's like very you know we just have a
small budget and then one of the things
that I realized by going to the meetups
that I had two it was the best of the
world because I could tackle two things
at the same time one is I was learning
for free
I was meeting people I was seeing what
was going on I was learning a lot and
the second piece that all the meetups
here they had food usually they had
pizza but that was good so I was
learning for free and I had my dinner
every night at the Meetup so it was the
best of the world for me having at the
opportunity to go through all these
meetups so by going off the by going by
uh by going at these meetups I realized
a few things I realized that
the the hosts and everybody going and
organizing those events they were doing
that on a volunteer base they were doing
that after work uh they were not getting
paid to do this type of events you know
it kind of like amazed me like that how
much effort and time people were putting
on this
um
and then I started to think you know
this is very cool I'm so glad that
people are doing this and then after
going to this meetups I was like okay
maybe it's my time it's my time to
give back right so it's a cycle I'm
getting all of this you know I have to
give back and this is a cycle so you get
you you receive and then you give back
you get you receive and then you give
back uh that's at least it's what I
believe so I was thinking about how can
I give back uh I don't know I don't know
if I can if there is anything that I can
give back I don't know if there is any
contribution that I can I can do uh so I
was thinking about that so after
thinking I started to to go through my
history what are the things I was doing
uh before that and then
R yes R was a big piece of me like I I
was learning art for a while uh that was
you know the time there between store
you needed to have a CD
to install your machine internet was
kind of like not a big thing yet uh all
the tutorials that we had were in
English uh very CS I would say Focus uh
very hard to understand but I but I knew
a little bit about R and I was
interested in learning more and getting
to our uh more often in another reason
how our our worked in the whole data
Science World work as well so I was like
well
how can I do this I know a little bit R
I can learn more I can teach I can learn
I can teach I'm like okay maybe I should
create something around r
but one of the things that I notice is
by going to these meetups I was always
in the corner not feeling very welcome
or in a safe environment I was like what
about if I do something where I can
create this environment that is going to
be friendlier that people will feel safe
without judgment where people can be
there themselves where we can have this
space where we are going to learn share
and grow together so that's how our
ladies was born Our Ladies was born in
San Francisco in October in 2012 in the
first meet up that we hosted was in
October there is a funny story about
this uh
about the first event that I'm going to
share the first event was on the
31st so I was very excited there is uh
we we got Google to host Us in San
Francisco this very very pretty office
we had a dinner very fast dinner and
then I was very excited I'm okay this is
this looks awesome right I'm going to
talk about ah it's going to be awesome
and I'm just going to go back a little
bit here and I'm going to do an
introduction to our uh for beginners and
beginners it's very exciting uh it's
awesome I'm sure a lot of people will
come
then
by the time it was time for us to start
the Meetup only eight people showed up
and I was very upset I was very upset
what is going on why we only have eight
people and then by the end of my
presentation someone came to me and said
hey Gabriella do you know what do you
know why we only have eight people here
and I'm like what like I I can't get it
and she was like well it's Halloween in
San Francisco and in Halloween San
Francisco it's a big deal so everybody's
on the streets potting you should
consider yourself lucky that eight
people showed up and I'm like okay so
first lesson learned never ever again
host uh in-person Meetup during
Halloween
anyway fast forward to 2022 uh 10 years
of Our Ladies Our Ladies became Global
in 2016 and nowadays we are pretty much
all over the world in several cities uh
with a hundred thousand members in more
than 60 countries and you can see that
there are a lot of chapters across the
globe and more than numbers like numbers
are good right because it's a way for us
you quantify the impact and to have an
idea of like the impact that the
organization is having globally right
but I would say that numbers the major
important impacts that I see are some
other things so I'm going to talk about
some of the impacts that a lot of people
don't see and they only see the numbers
and all they care it's numbers so
number one
it was to create a safe feeling in a
welcoming environment for people to
learn so you I can show on the pictures
you can see there are several different
uh meetups when we used to meet in
person luckily
things are shifting back again uh so
there are a lot of like different
meetups in Africa and EOS in Asia Middle
East where people get together to learn
and one of the things that I love about
this picture and it's very uh
two for some cities is like you don't
need to have a computer to get together
and learn ah or learn anything right so
like uh maybe you don't have internet
maybe you don't have computer but you
can still have this time to get together
in line and have this community
surrounded you and I love this picture
because this is the reality in in
several cities in the world uh the other
thing is about empowering it's
empowering folks from all backgrounds to
start to change or to advance careers
um
we have like several types of like
meetups uh different domains different
Technologies different methodologies
different uh
tools are in different languages here
are some examples of like the meetups
that were hosted throughout the years
there is one in data science GitHub or
python analytics ai ai ethics uh
epidemiology our studio and so on uh the
other thing is about being part of this
large and supportive Network
where no matter where you are probably
there is a chapter or like a local
community that you can be part of but if
there isn't there is also like something
that our ladies did which is to connect
people that are geographically isolated
uh this is something that we notice and
this was before the pandemic we noticed
that some people really wanted to join
our ladies but they didn't have a local
chapter so our latest remote was created
in a way to connect people that were
isolated or that the time of the meetups
that were being hosted were not
compatible with uh what they uh with
their times and so on
the other thing that is very interesting
is like by joining this community or
other communities you connect with
different communities so we see our
ladies and and ladies it's one example
but like how we have this Synergy with
different communities how we work with
different communities How We Do events
with different communities so here are
some of the examples including Pi data
where we do this cross-collaboration
again talking about global uh is it's a
it's an opportunity for you to connect
with people from all over the world uh
one very fun thing that happens in every
our conference is oh there are ladies uh
we get together to take a picture and
you can see how uh the picture or you
know the number of people in the picture
has changed throughout the years where
before it was you know it could fit like
in 2018 it could fit in like in in a
room and it was easy to take a picture
and then in 2020 it was like there is no
way that we can take the picture of like
everybody together like there is no
place or room or space you can see
people all over in the hallway over here
trying to wave uh so this is very cool
like you connect with people from all
over the world uh the other things
around creating allies is sponsorship
mentorship and lifelong connections how
many people we know and I know
personally that mad through all ladies
and became friends became co-workers
became kind of like a family
um
and one of the questions that people ask
again going back to to the the
uh the importance of like communities is
they ask
how do you see our ladies how do you see
these organizations changing the
landscape in this case how do you see
the organ how do you see the
organization changing the landscape of
the our project and again this is very
hard to show it's very hard to quantify
what is the impact uh I always like to
say you know look at the pictures the
pictures tell uh can can tell you more
than words and numbers just look at the
pictures just go to the conferences and
you'll see the impact how our ladies
change it there are ecosystem or the r
um
the art project but one of the the ways
that this showed up was uh there was a
community survey that was read uh the
the Arkansas Consortium ran where there
were some questions and one of the
questions uh was
the best aspect of working with r
and you can see here the community was
the the one that people mentioned the
most and this was a free-form uh
questionnaire for this question and you
can see the communities like the whole
the heart of working with r which is
very like there is nothing that I can
say that is more impactful than having a
survey where you have community in their
hearts uh of the of the response
um
and then just to finalize here it's no
matter what we do community is like this
piece missing piece when you look back
to your career there is always some
aspect the community even though you
don't realize that there is a community
uh
closer to it it can be like the
community that uh
your co-workers or something that you do
at work or it can be like through an
organization or it can be through your
work as for example in my case as a
cloud advocate so communities like this
missing piece that I think it's always
missing in all projects everything that
we do uh and it's the heart and it's the
essential piece uh that it's link it's
the linking piece that connects all the
parts
so that's all I want to share with you
today I want to thank you again for the
invitation for your time and I would
love that's my favorite part I would
love to open for questions uh any
questions that you have
um I'm here for you now
yeah thank you so much um yeah we've got
a couple comments uh throughout the uh
presentation some questions
um if you do have a question you can
just post it in the YouTube and we'll
grab it and um pull it up but yeah
please let's have any questions you
might have
yeah why why people are writing uh
questions
um I want to mention code spaces again
it's free uh you should have the same
button that I was showing on my GitHub
uh in your
GitHub
um let me go back to my GitHub again you
know GitHub repo so you can open any any
repo that you have you should have this
button over here uh I I have to stop all
of this because I open a lot of like
different machines uh but the other
piece is like you you have control like
let's say as a student you have 90 hours
and you want to make sure that you are
not in the limits there is a way in your
setting that you can see how much you
have used so far so there is all about
the control uh how much you are using
um again for General audiences 60 hours
for students it's 90 hours
um
so this is pretty cool and if anyone has
any questions around this I would love
to you know you can tweet or ask me on
Twitter or any other vehicle uh question
about it
um
so let's see there is one question and
I'm going to stop my
back I'm good the first one from Emily
yes so I can see the questions all right
so Emily is asking
how would you tell code space What
python version package version you want
for your project that's a great question
Emily if you have you can have
something like
requirements.txt you can have that and
that will mimic uh the the environment
that you have so make sure that
everybody has the same uh the same
environment so that would be one way
where you can have this file that tells
you you know this is all the
requirements that we need the thing that
I was showing here because it's very
simple I didn't have to install any
pandas or matplotlib it was already
installed beforehand because some of the
main used libraries they come with the
with with this virtual environment but
if there is any any specific packages or
versions that you want you you can
specify in your project kind of like the
same way that you would do without code
spaces like when someone go in and clone
and then you have a requirement file
that you have to install all the
prerequisites to run that would work
kind of like the same way
oh I we have yes free shama uh how do
you think Community has evolved during
the pandemic and do you have any
suggestions
yeah it's been very hard for communities
in general uh to survive and thrive
during the pandemic
um
AI inclusive was the when I launched AI
inclusive was right before the epidemic
and my idea was to do like the same
thing as in person and all of that and
then we had to shift uh because we
couldn't meet more in person anymore so
I had to think about ways to keep
reaching the community keep creating
impacts and adjust to the new reality so
instead of like hosting in personally we
couldn't anymore and there was also like
a saturation of online events happening
so there are two things that I I feel
like it worked one of them was to
partner with different organizations
different communities instead of doing
your own partner with others because
there is a every day we used to have one
or two or three events happening so if
you partner you are expanding a
community you are not overflowing
everybody with all this video and
meetings and meetups online
and and you can reach more people as
well so this is one of the things the
other piece was around is there anything
that we can do that is going to reach uh
the global community so we shift to
offer like uh scholarship uh through
boot camps that were going on online so
anyone could take those online courses
or classes uh in in no matter where you
were so those were the things that we
did uh so a suggestion that worked for
us and I feel like we can replicate this
in other communities uh
I don't know like how things will change
when we come back and they see like you
know it's like it's like a psycho it's
like going bad and then we go back in
person but not everybody is is is
comfortable uh so I I still think that
we are going to be involving uh as as we
go
hey Dennis uh yes
uh so any advice to meet up organizers
and hosts to make the events more
welcoming to everyone I would say it
starts from the beginning like who are
the people who hosting or organizing do
you have a set of like live worse people
behind it so that's the first thing
because it's the front
the front door it's like who is
organizing who is hosting so I would say
that's the first step making sure that
we have a diverse set of organizers or
hosts uh behind it uh the other piece is
like having a code of conduct for all
the meetups and events and conferences
and and any any interaction that we have
we we read the kind of conduct we make
sure that everybody's aware of the kind
of contact so this is the same that's
the first thing that we do as we start
an event we say hey we have this kind of
conduct let me read
um a little bit for you so you are aware
and you also enforce this code of
conduct if there is any any issue there
is an enforcement in a channel that you
can reach
um so those are some advices that I I
can offer uh from the top of my head
thank you
oh yeah so great question Thiago so how
have you gone about training and
supporting other leaders across the
globe as part of our ladies so they
could run their chapters as well
um
so we had first of all we had a slack
Channel where all the organizers would
get into so they all have Compact and
they could learn from each other from
the from the from the slack Channel and
then we had a guide
where
kind of like best practices on how to
run
um an event how to what are some of the
materials that you can use can you reuse
other materials from other chapters uh
if you have any questions you have this
whole network of like other organizers
that are there that you can ask
questions so that's what we did so we
did the slack with all the organizers we
had a guide for all the the chapter
leaders of anyone wanting to organizing
um to organize a chapter
oh great so G Villa is is asking advice
on how to become an ambassador can you
become an ambassador for a boot camp
institution they have a very diverse
population they don't have dot edu
emails yes you can
um
my suggestion would be go through
um first through the GitHub because
GitHub has a good uh process of like
validating if you are a student in a
university or an institution even though
you don't have an edu email so go
through GitHub first go for the
validation and then you can go to Azure
for students to sign up
um that would be my advice the other
thing is like try to make uh try to keep
in touch with any Ambassador that you
you know or let me see if I can find the
there is a website where you can find
all the ambassadors and if there is any
Ambassador
um
here let me just sound it on the on the
chat real quick uh so there is this
place over here where you can find all
these student ambassadors you can also
get in touch with them to see uh if they
have any tips or any anything that they
can share on how to become an ambassador
or you can reach out to me and I can
help you on on
on how to navigate this path
that might be uh for the questions those
are good questions so thank you for
adding those
um maybe I'll just add on this little
comment here hopefully Sven doesn't mind
posting it but thank you so much for uh
joining us as a keynote uh this really
has been great